oh my god there are skills
chicken nuggets pasta salad shall we oh
boy strong
dinner party Feasts
[Music]
hi I'm Hannah I'm the world's okayest
mom and the other night I had a thought
thank you pregnancy insomnia I love
making wacky foods for my kids and
interesting new foods for them to try so
for an entire week I'm gonna only cook
recipes from the 1950s I really want to
put myself to the test and see if I can
withstand this 1950s challenge I tried
my best to get a variety of proteins
really good a good sense of what the
cuisine was like in 1950s America so I
really wanted to accumulate this week
with a giant 1950s dinner party so of
course I had to reach out to my mom I
had to find all of my old vintage
cookbooks I had to definitely pick her
brain for some advice hi Mom hi honey so
I need some help because I'm planning to
host a 1950s themed dinner party for my
friends and I just wanted to know if you
have any advice time of the party have
your hair done your makeup done your
ready you know you've got your little
hostess apron on and have all the
ambience like 50s right I don't have a
tablecloth or an apron is that necessary
yes yes honey it is you don't do 50s
without that I want to buy that for you
because I know you probably won't I
don't want to send you the cash for it
though what should I do oh you can
actually just send me the money with
Zell because we already enrolled you do
you remember I do it makes it so easy
all you have to do is add my phone
number and click the money will go to my
bank account in minutes oh my God you've
been trying to get me to buy a
tablecloth I know you won't regret it
it's gonna be so much fun thank you for
sending me money even though I'm in my
30s anytime honey all right love you Mom
love you honey bye I'm armed with a very
lengthy grocery list and we'll see if I
can find anything it wasn't complicated
but there were a lot of items that I had
never purchased before so I'm gonna head
home and sort through all these
groceries and hope I didn't forget
anything and we will see what's up
dinner time and I'm gonna make something
that actually sounded really fancy when
I saw the recipe title but it actually
is really really simple so the first
recipe I wanted to try was chicken
croquettes I've never made a croquette
personally I definitely wanted to start
this week off with something that
everyone would enjoy and so it's got
some of those core foods that everybody
likes a lot of these 50s recipes are
very chicken heavy a lot of chicken
going on there's not a whole lot of
vegetables so I think I'm gonna have to
pair this with a salad of some sort two
tablespoons of minced celery which is
basically the equivalent of like if I
thought about celery while I was eating
this dish there are some ingredients
that feel like they're just there to be
there I was a little confused over the
celery but at the end of the day it was
something fresh this feels very under
seasoned I will just say that okay
one
Patty now these are not cooked in butter
these are fried in
shortening
how very 50s
oh are you hungry yeah okay
it's kind of like chicken nuggets this
is amazing you like it what would you
give it out of ten what number
10. two yeah
oh well he's gone in for another bite so
that's good okay let's see what the
biggest kid likes
um you know what I'm getting like strong
pot pie vibes
oh
tree seasoning is very timey
it's very good it was something that my
family didn't even realize might have
been out of the norm for this day and
age it's all ingredients that everyone's
very familiar with everyone enjoyed it
everybody ate it it was really tasty and
really easy this morning I'm making a
classic 50s breakfast you see it at
every American Diner it's kind of still
here like the classic 50s breakfast but
what I did not factor in is that I have
a 9 A.M doctor's appointment
and I didn't time manage well enough I
was very tired this morning so I'm a bad
50s housewife what do you think of when
you think of like a classic American
breakfast because for me it's eggs bacon
and pancakes okay Jackson requested a
smiley face this reminds me of a goofy
movie look how cute
it's lunchtime and you know what we're
having for lunch
vegetables no no
some hearty ham sandwiches I mean
sometimes in life you just throw
together a ham sandwich and that's lunch
and so I felt very realistic to me are
you redressing your sandwich
yes I don't know mustard is something
that
oh yes
oh yes you have a deconstructed ham
sandwich wouldn't be a 50s week without
a little bit of tuna I couldn't let the
week go by without making a tuna noodle
casserole
tuna yes
what do you think it's good it's good oh
this is a little full okay what am I
doing
oh I made a mistake
huh the final thing that
my mom said I cannot forget is crushed
potato chips on top close your mouth
what do you think
you don't like it
do you like it
yeah okay but with Henry and Wyatt were
hesitant to try it at first I think just
because tuna is a strong smell but once
everyone got that first bite in
everybody loved it what do you think
really good tasty yeah
oh yeah while we were on a roll with
fish casseroles I had to try one other
fish casserole that I had seen in a
couple recipe books which is a salmon
surprise my hope is that
the surprises it sounds very Bland but
it's actually very flavorful I bought
this like bougie can of salmon and when
I opened it it had all of the bones and
skin in it oh my god there are skills
but I wasn't gonna let this salmon go to
waste so I spent a lot of time picking
out all of the bones I realized my
Mayo's vegan I hope this is okay
parmesan so I found a lot of these
recipes from family recipes and I feel
like the parmesan is an addition after
the fact that doesn't seem too
authentically 50s maybe we're cheating a
little bit with this parmesan but most
of the recipes I've seen are like
American cheese or cheddar so basically
what I think this surprise was
is like layered almost scalloped
potatoes on top of the salmon two layers
down and one to go
I had to add the green salad I just had
to it was there was so much beige but I
think the green salad is allowed I
didn't add anything to it it's just
greens Jackson is my garbage disposal I
say it all the time he loves everything
I make he's really easy to please just
give him a plate of food and he's happy
so he was thoroughly impressed with all
of these 50s recipes because it was
something new here you go love Jackson's
not feeling so good so we're just being
careful
and there's your surprise it really
looks like scalloped potatoes it does
right you like it
oh good
oh my goodness
you like it you got creamy potatoes and
cheese it's gonna be good and the salmon
honestly was very mild it wasn't super
fishy the tuna casserole was a lot
fishier in taste what do you think of
your dinner
do you like it more than the other meals
or what's your favorite so far
I think I like the chicken
from cats croquettes
today's dinner
sounds interesting but it
it's a ground beef biscuit casserole and
it actually has quite a few vegetables
in it so I'm very excited you know we're
really on a casserole streak here I feel
like it's not all casseroles this week I
promise it's about one cup of celery and
one cup of carrots it honestly it was
almost like the beef version of a pot
pie or like a drop biscuit pot pie I was
supposed to drain and discard the grease
and I just added my butter to the grease
ah hold on oh geez I dropped you I'm
sorry what do I put this in
oh boy okay so I really wasn't equipped
with the amount of cookie utensils
needed or maybe I just wasn't a good
enough 50s housewife keeping up with the
dishes quick enough don't mind my beater
whisk
my whisk is always dirty these days
trying to mix this butter with the flour
nobody panic
I'm gonna add these veggies
seasoning with a little
garlic powder and I'm gonna bring this
to a boil so I don't have a cookie
cutter so I'm cutting the biscuits out
with a glass
this is not as pretty as I envisioned
what'd you put in your mouth that's not
food
that's very good for Wyatt it definitely
was a challenge
but the biscuits on top made it a lot
more palatable for him
this stick really good
Matt said it reminded him of his
childhood does it please my husband it
pleases me while I was on a roll with
nostalgic Foods this week I had to bring
back a classic and make some beef
stroganoff got some mushrooms and onions
cooking down here this smells absolutely
incredible
of some egg noodles and some steak I
knew it was going to be a creamy dish I
just didn't realize how much sour cream
is in that meal another kind of gray
dish that it smells fantastic here we
have the plated dish and of course I'm
serving it alongside
a salad
I think they just called it a salad like
not meaning salad I think I'm just
reading into this but I love the idea of
serving it alongside a salad made out of
jello everybody loved it so that's a win
for me that means it's on my list of
repeat meals but it is intense you leave
the table feeling full well someone dug
right in
is it good
this is actually jello
time to serve
now the key to a good dinner party is
plenty of appetizers and plenty of
entrees all of these recipes had
extensive preparations so I needed to
carve out an entire day for dinner party
prep is this cream cheese
uh with which I'm going to make olive
stuffed celery a lot of seasonings for
our 50s recipe going on here so the
thing that threw me off for the olive
stuff celery was it had a ton of chopped
pecans in it which when I'm thinking of
a bunch of different types of olives
and pickles and like cream cheese and
celery I'm not thinking like let's throw
some nuts on this looks and smells very
good it's not a 50s week without an
ambrosia salad many marshmallows I have
pineapple tidbits and canned Mandarin
oranges so my final dish is potato salad
I've never made potato salad from
scratch I am a very big fan of buying
potato salad at the grocery store and as
for entrees I wanted to make chicken a
la king because that was another dish
that Matt recognized and remembered my
grandma used to have
boxes of it in her freezer every 50s
dinner party needs like the Crown Jewel
dish so I decided to make a giant spiral
sliced ham come on stay on come on
Friends
two more slices where should they go
right now I'm making a cherry angel food
cake I have my sifted flour I have my
bundt pan I have my diced maraschino
cherries I have my egg whites I'm gonna
fold
the flower in until there are no more
streaks
got a couple lumps but I just don't want
to
mess with it or deflate it anymore
doing great everybody I'm just gonna
clean it up a little
get those straggly stuff and then pop it
in the oven this cake was very touch and
go and did not want to come out of the
pan a good dinner party host is put
together she's got her hair done she's
got her makeup done she's got a cool
apron and I just I wanted to look the
part
actually these rollers are kind of nice
kind of like them wow I look good it
looks like you're on the fancy one uh
like uh what was it like a business area
so the final step to an epic dinner
party is the tablescape all right here
we are
[Music]
here it is
what did you think of the candy place
two different kinds of pickles three
different kinds of olives
I'm gonna
make her yeah
how's the ham
this reminds me of my grandma
okay the chicken is very good
I am so bad at filming when I have
people over because I'm trying to host
the whole time
dinner party was a big success the food
went over really well so that's all for
now I'm Hannah and please tell me would
you eat or make any of these 1950s
recipes let me know on Instagram and if
you'll please excuse me I'm gonna put my
feet up and just be horizontal for a
while spend a lot of time on my feet
till next time
[Music]
thank you
[Music]